in the years since harry potter's story
ended
jk rowling has revealed a whole lot more
about the world she created
occasionally stirring up a little
controversy along the way here are the
biggest revelations rowling has shared
with fans since finishing the harry
potter books
it's pretty much a hard rule that any
fantasy epic that follows the hero's
journey has got to have an old wise man
present to teach the young protagonists
how to overcome their hurdles and
challenges
of course harry potter is no exception
enter albus dumbledore
the headmaster of hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
who begins the series watching over the
orphaned infant harry from a distance
and eventually becomes a major parental
figure for the character during their
shared time at hogwarts
even after dumbledore dies in half-blood
prince
his shadow looms large all the way
through to the final moments of the
series
now there's plenty harry doesn't know
about dumbledore
but one facet of his character couldn't
have been guessed by even the sharpest
of readers
in 2007 rowling revealed that dumbledore
was gay
and though fans knew he had a close
friendship with the wizard grindelwald
in his younger days
most fans didn't take that to mean that
the two were more than friends
though dumbledore's orientation never
needed to be addressed by the story
this was still quite a surprise for fans
who could now look at the character in
an entirely new light
rowling even claims to have clued in one
of the film's screenwriters to this
reveal
nixing a would-be dumbledore line about
an old female flame
after dropping the big bombshell about
dumbledore's sexuality
rowling waited nearly 10 years to push
the issue again
ahead of the release of the second film
in the potter spin-off series
fantastic beasts and where to find them
both rowling and director david yates
faced
serious backlash over comments made by
yates stating that dumbledore's
sexuality wouldn't be directly addressed
in the second fantastic beasts movie
the crimes of grindelwald despite the
fact that the antagonist of the film
was famously known as dumbledore's lover
on the movie's blu-ray release
rowling followed up the controversy by
announcing that the two
had indeed gauged in an extremely
intense physical relationship
but this reveal didn't come without its
controversy with rowling's comments
raising some important questions about
representation
after all what does it say to lgbtq fans
that dumbledore fell in love with a
murderous villain
and then possibly lived in celibacy for
the remainder of his life
and why is that representation found
only on a blu-ray special feature
rather than within the story itself all
in all this particular reveal sent a
more muddled and confusing message than
rowling likely intended
one of the most fascinating acts of
magic in the entire wizarding world
is the patronus charm a difficult and
advanced spell which summons a magical
protector that seems to come from
inside a wizard's own spirit harry first
discovers his patronus in prisoner of
azkaban
where it takes the form of a stag in
honor of harry's late father james who
could transform into that same animal
after the story officially ended fans
wanted to know about the patronuses of
their favorite characters
from hermione's otter to luna lovegood's
rabbit
but one revelation about a truly beloved
character was particularly tragic
when asked what patronus might belong to
hogwarts groundskeeper
rubius hagrid rowling responded that
hagrid wasn't able to produce the spell
at all
likely thanks to his wrongful expulsion
from hogwarts as a teenager
this wasn't rowling's only patronus
revelation either
the author also noted that severus snape
was the only death eater who could
summon a patronus
since he was the only member of the evil
group with his soul still intact
after all this time
always harry potter fans still have
plenty of lingering questions about the
wizarding world
and to her credit rolling has answered
many of them but she has also
answered a few questions nobody ever
asked despite bathrooms
playing a weirdly significant role in
the series fans weren't exactly
clamoring to find out how
wizards got along before the days of
indoor plumbing even so
rowling was on hand to clear that one up
so to speak in early 2019
a tweet from harry potter website
pottermore revealed a pretty unexpected
fact about the wizarding world
apparently before wizards began using
muggle style plumbing
it basically just went right on the
floor and then got rid of it
using a vanishing spell weirdly enough
this wasn't
actually new information either
pottermore had previously revealed this
in a 2015 essay on the website but the
2019 tweet
caused far more of a stir with many fans
wondering why it even needed to be said
every long-running series needs an
iconic villain and voldemort
clearly fit the bill for harry potter
after trying to kill harry as an infant
and nearly perishing himself voldemort
spends the rest of his life on a mission
to defeat harry once and for all when
harry hears a prophecy about the two in
order of the phoenix
he realizes that he can't avoid his fate
for neither
can live while the other survives
after destroying voldemort's horcruxes
and sacrificing himself to defeat the
evil wizard
harry is finally able to best voldemort
once and for all
taking down one of the most nefarious
and murderous wizards the world has ever
seen
in fact voldemort was so nefarious and
murderous that most wizards refused to
even speak his name
instead many of them simply referred to
him as he who must not be named
or you know who voldemort voldemort
as it turns out however even though it's
bold enough to say
voldemort have been getting it all wrong
in 2015
rowling revealed she always meant
voldemort to be pronounced in the french
fashion with a silent t
voldemort since the name itself means
flight of death referring to the dark
wizard's own fear of death
pretty much everyone has actually been
pronouncing it incorrectly
from the fans to the films themselves
hermione granger has served as an
inspiration to brilliant and bookish
children
ever since her introduction in the first
book in the series though she initially
comes off as a frustrating know-it-all
to harry and ron
hermione quickly becomes one of the
series most virtuous and likable
characters
mental that one i'm telling you
heralded as the brightest witch of her
age hermione's love of learning and
quick thinking set her apart from other
students
even earning her a valuable and powerful
time turner in her third year at
hogwarts
hermione's ingenuity serves the trio
particularly well in deathly hallows
when she secretly packs all of their
most valuable belongings into a tiny
beaded evening bag
which she has bewitched to hold an
enormous amount of objects
though this magical object proves
crucial in the final push to defeat
voldemort it turns out that hermione
actually broke
wizarding law by putting an extension
charm on the bag
although she was never taken to task for
it probably because people had bigger
things on their mind
even after the harry potter series ended
the concept
of sorting has played a big role in the
post potter world with pretty much every
potter fan out there
sorting themselves into one of hogwarts
four personality based
houses whether you're a brave gryffindor
a hard-working hufflepuff
a brilliant ravenclaw or a cunning
slytherin
most fans know which house they identify
with the most
and when pottermore debuted in 2011 it
featured the first ever definitive
sorting quiz
written by rowling herself for most
people sorting is fairly straightforward
still rowling used pottermore to reveal
the concept of a hat stall
which happens when a person who shares
traits that fit into multiple houses
causes the sorting hat to get stuck on
where to place them
sometimes for more than five minutes
even though the hat struggled with harry
harry isn't considered a hat stall
hermione nearly was
as the hat struggled to choose between
gryffindor and ravenclaw
his classmate neville longbottom's long
sorting process meanwhile
came down to a fight between neville and
the hat over whether or not he was brave
enough for gryffindor
spoiler alert he was as it turns out
however harry actually did
know two hat styles his transfiguration
professor minerva mcgonagall
and his parents own personal judas peter
pettigrew
both ended up in gryffindor after nearly
ending up in ravenclaw and slytherin
respectively fans have asked plenty of
questions about hogwarts itself over the
years but one particular issue seems to
have weighed heavy on their minds
what do students actually do before they
enroll at the school
since students don't start hogwarts
until they hit 11 years of age
many fans wondered what young magical
children did before their seven-year
schooling career began
in an interview with time after the book
series came to a close
rowling answered several remaining
questions about the books
and one revelation cleared up this exact
question during the interview
rowling confirmed that young wizarding
children are homeschooled
since many younger witches and wizards
have trouble controlling their magic
and must be kept at home so they don't
reveal themselves to muggles by mistake
before harry learns that he's a wizard
and starts attending hogwarts he spends
11 miserable years
living with his aunt petunia and uncle
vernon as well as their son dudley
the dursleys all despise harry and treat
him terribly
even forcing the orphan to sleep in a
spider-ridden cupboard under the stairs
it's later revealed that petunia was
jealous of her sister's magical ability
despite frequently calling lily a freak
her detestable husband vernon is equally
incensed by the magical world
with the two of them swearing that
they'll never let harry be a wizard
until hogwarts eventually intervenes
you're a wizard harry even with the
specter of magic
hanging over them it's still a bit
baffling that vernon and petunia would
be
so angry and resentful to a small child
rowling eventually revealed that issues
between the dursleys and harry's parents
went all the way back to a double date
gone wrong
during which james antagonized dursleys
to the point of no return
as he grows up harry's growing
resemblance to his father
infuriates the dursleys and uncle vernon
in particular
one of the strangest figures that lives
within hogwarts walls has got to be
moaning myrtle the ghost of a young girl
killed by the basilisk that resides
inside the chamber of secrets
clearly myrtle has had some trouble
letting go since she haunts the very
bathroom where she died
and she spends her time wreaking havoc
haunting students and generally being
kind of annoying
thanks to this myrtle is generally
considered one of the school's least
liked ghosts
at one point rowling decided to reveal
myrtle's full name
which was previously unknown to readers
taking to twitter the author announced
that myrtle's name is
actually myrtle elizabeth warren though
she was quick to disavow any relation
between hogwarts weirdest ghost
and the accomplished american senator
while the books were still being written
die hard fans engaged in constant
arguments about hermione's love life
hotly debating whether she should end up
with harry or ron
by the time the later books in the
series came around however it had become
relatively clear in which direction
rowling was leaning
mine has got nice skin wouldn't you say
as skin goes i mean
i've never really thought about it but i
suppose yeah i think i'll be going to
sleep now
right in the end she paired hermione
with ron
capitalizing on their years of tension
and many differences
harry meanwhile ended up with jenny
ron's feisty and talented younger sister
however rolling ascents changed course
saying she wished hermione had ended up
with harry after all
she claimed that the relationship
between ron and hermione was simply a
form of wish fulfillment for her
vindicating some fans while infuriating
others
for fans who love the fiery intense
relationship between ron and hermione
however
this felt like a total betrayal by
rowling to date this
incident is counted as one of the most
famous examples of rowling making an
unnecessary reveal
one that many fans wish she had kept to
herself check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you